(television static)
- I just don't think
people believe me.
(television static)
I think 99.9--
Your country is not the variable
of your hustle, my friend.
(television static)
Now, the environment that,
like, entrepreneurship
is glorified in the US,
the UK wants to be more
reserved, different, you know?
(television static)
And your hustle,
your work ethic, your drive,
is not predicated
on your zip code.
(television static)
(light music)
So, first of all, it's
different for everyone.
But this whole notion of,
like, "Where is the time"...
I just think people are
loaded with excuses.
I think that the Vayner Nation
thinks they're hustling,
and straight to your face,
I think 99.9% of you are not.
Everybody has time.
Stop watching fucking "Lost".
The thought and
nature of people saying,
"Well, America is an
entrepreneurial paradise,"
is the same conversation that's
happening within America.
Like, to be great in tech, you
need to be in San Francisco.
And let me just remind
everybody that Facebook
was invented in Boston.
I'm just worried that
people don't have patience.
There's so many
people giving up.
I think the fear
of losing trumps
the excitement of victory
for so many people.
So, to me, hustle would
be putting all your effort
into achieving the goal at hand.
And, for me, that means
making every minute count.
Look, you need a break? Good.
Get your break,
but the bottom line is
every minute that you
can apply to your game,
you need to.
I worry that people don't
tap into their strengths.
I think that people
like to claim
that they work hard and smart,
but they're not
putting in the work,
and they work 9:00 to 6:00.
It's just not enough.
Executing the way it always is,
following the school
business model,
is just such horse shit.
It's gonna lead you to place
where you're not going to win.
Your talent isn't enough.
You've gotta go put in the work.
And having thick skin.
Do you know how obnoxiously
thick my skin is?
You can punch me
in the face 8,000 times.
I'm here to get punched.
Whether you're 100 or zero,
and wanna zen and live on a
mountain with no technology,
or you wanna buy the Jets
and hustle your face off,
or anything in between,
you need to find your cadence.
There is no reason
to do shit you hate!
None.
Promise me you won't.
Whatever you need to do, do it.
Look yourself in the
mirror, and ask yourself,
"What do I want to do every
day for the rest of my life?"
Do that!
And then hustle your
face off 15 hours a day
to get people to care.
You know what I hustle about?
I hustle about meeting every
single person on earth.
Do you know why?
Because I care about people
more than I care about myself.
You're spending an hour
or two on things every day
that aren't achieving
this extra brand
or extra monies
that you're chasing.
And that's what you need to do.
You need to work so hard.
Your talent isn't enough.
You've gotta go put in the work,
and the fact of the
matter is we're in a time
and in a generation that's
not willing to do that.
Do I have angst? Sure.
I'm calling out myself every day
for the last six or seven years,
telling everybody
I'm gonna buy the Jets.
I gotta roll billy's deep.
I mean, if you want this,
if you want bling-bling,
if you wanna buy the Jets,
if you wanna do shit,
work!
That's how you get it.
Hustle is putting it
all on the line.
Period.
Simple.
You don't like
the way it sounds.
Fuck it, 'cause it's the truth,
'cause you're just not working.
Hustle is waking up one
day, the day before you die,
and realizing you
gave it your all,
into the parenting
of your children,
the building of your businesses,
the philanthropy that
you wanted to do.
Whatever you define, it's just,
you know, all in,
emotionally and executionally,
in theory, and strategy,
and in execution.
Hustle is a word to
so many people,
even to some of
my hardcore fans.
I'm sorry to call you out,
but I follow you
like you follow me.
And people talk
about the hustle,
but then you're talking about
your 6:00 happy hour drink,
or your video game,
or this and that.
And here we are in the holidays,
and everybody's going
to their holiday party,
and I've got one meeting
coming up right now,
two meetings after that,
reviewing all my email.
And so while everybody's
drinking some goddamned eggnog,
I continue the hustle.
And so you can say it,
or you can do it,
but I highly recommend
you do both.
Stop crying and
just keep hustling.
Hustle is the
most important word ever!
(light music)
(television static)
(loud television static)